secondaire et de ce point de vue je
pense qu'il est utile
c'est sur le 24 alinéa 2
de dire que scatter Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine on peut le comprendre mais ça
n'est pas adapté
parce que ce qui est en question ici ce
n'est pas de savoir si la publicité est
obligatoire la question il est de savoir
elle est de savoir si le ministre n'a
pas dit la vérité
parce que depuis le début
lorsque nous avons demandé cet avis
lorsque nous avons demandé cet avis au
gouvernement il ne nous a pas été
répondu vous ne l'aurez pas car il n'a
pas d'obligation de publicité on aurait
pu apprécier polémiquer contester ce
n'est pas ce qui nous a été dit il nous
a été dit il n'y a pas d'avis il a
simplement une note or
Marie-Noëlle linman vous la luge vous
suggère d'aller sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et vous verrez le
Facilier du projet tel qu'il a été
déposé à l'Assemblée nationale et qui
dit expressément que le texte a été
adopté en conseil des ministres après
avis du Conseil d'État donc le point qui
est aujourd'hui soulevé madame la
Présidente c'est de savoir pourquoi le
ministre nous a dit autre chose que la
vérité qui sauf à nous dire que ce qui
est écrit dans le document du de
l'Assemblée nationale qu'est-ce qui
suffit monsieur le ministre thème de la
Gontrie sincère non mais vous l'avez
interpellé est-ce que vous avez dit
n'est pas très respectueux d'un membre
du gouvernement c'est totalement
Ueux que de dire alors
que le ministre ne nous a pas dit la
véritément de l'Assemblée nationale
qu'il s'agit d'un avis
[Musique]